التدريبات العسكريه الامريكيه الكوريه
الجنوبيه المسماه الدرع لتعزيز القدرات
البلدين الدفاعيه تثير حفيظه كوريا
الشماليه
تبدا المناورات في الثالث عشر من هذا
الشهر وتستمر عشره ايام بلا انقطاع وقال
البلدان ان مناوراتهما تجري في اطار
سيناريوهات الواقعيه تحاكي التهديدات
النوويه التي تمثلها كوريا الشماليه كان
الجيش الامريكي والجيش الكوري الجنوبي قد
اجريا مناورات جويه مشتركه اشهر الماضي
قالت سول انها سمحت باظهار القدره على نشر
الفوري لوسائل الردع الامريكيه الموسعه في
شبه الجزيره الكوريه
جاء ذلك عقب اطلاق كوريا الشماليه صاروخا
عابرا للقارات سقط في مياه اليابان وقالت
بيونغيانج ان تجربته تهدف الى تعزيز
قدرتها الهجوميه النوويه القاتله
وشملت التدريبات الامريكيه الكوريه
الجنوبيه استخدام قاذفه امريكيه من طراز
بي 1 ومقاتلات الشبح اف 35 ومقاتلات اف 15
واف سته عشر الامريكيه
كوريا الشماليه انتقدت تدريبات درع الحريه
المرتقبه ووصفتها مع غيرها من التدريبات
بانها استعدادات لشن حرب عدوانيه عليها
وحذرت من ان سولوا واشنطن ستواجهان ردود
فعل قويه وغير مسبوقه وقالت
ان اطلاقها الشهر الماضي صاروخا باليسيا
عاذرا للقارات من طراز هو سونج 15 يندرج
في اطار تدريبات لردع الخصوم وقد تصاعدت
حده التوتر في شبه جزيره الكوريه منذ
اعلان الزعيم الكوري الشمالي كيم جون اون
رسميا في سبتمبر الماضي سياسه تجعل من
الوضعيه النوويه لبلاده امرا لا رجعت فيه
واجرت عددا قياسيا من التجارب على اسلحتها
بما في ذلك الصواريخ الباليستيه العابره
للقارات
انا من اوكسفورد
جوليو بولينزي استاذ العلاقات الدوليه
المختص بشؤون الاسيويه بجامعه اوسفورد
مرحبا بك سيد جوليو
يعني ان تقول كوريا الشماليه ان هذه
التدريبات الامريكيه الكوريه الجنوبيه
تهدف الى شن حرب عليها او غزو كوريا
الشماليه ما مدى واقعيه هذا التخوف
الذي تبديه كوريا الشماليه ازاءه تلك
التدريبات
صحيح انه كان هنالك
زياده في التدريبات
العسكريه وقرب ايضا بالقرب من شبه الجزيره
الكوريه لان الاداره الامريكيه ترغب
بالانخراطي
بدفع وضغط على كوريا الشماليه من اجل ان
تدخل كوريا الشماليه في اتفاق من اجل
السيطره على برنامجها النووي كان وهذا
يهدف الى
تحجيمي كوريا الشماليه بالتالي
نشهده الان
هو موقف متوتر في نتيجه هذه
بسبب التنافس بين الصين
والولايات المتحده
كوريا الجنوبيه تريد ان حول مساله الرد
النوويه في المنطقه والولايات المتحده
تحتاج ان توفر وتستثمر هذا الامر بالتالي
ان ايضا يكون هنالك تنظيم لعمليه الفعل
ورد الفعل ياتي هذا عن طريق التدريبات
العسكريه المتزايده لكن من الواضح ان
العناصر تهدف وكل ما يحدث يهدف الى الردع
والتصميم الحلفاء بدلا من مساله
لكن في المقابل يعني
يجب النظر في المقابل الى كوريا الشماليه
هل تتوقع ان يكون لديها رد فعل ازاء هذه
التدريبات
من الواضح انها قد
قفزت واستغلت هذه المنافق المناسبه من اجل
استعراض قدراتها الصاروخيه النوويه قد
نشهد قريبا ربما
عمليه اطلاق صواريخ نوويه جديده بالتالي
كوريا الشماليه تريد ان تظهر انها
تمتلك الصواريخ النوويه هي اطلقت اطلق
اكبر عدد من اساوري في عام 2022 مره اخرى
الغرض من ذلك سيكون هو الردع لكن علينا ان
نضمن ان الازمات يتم
ادارتها بدون زياده في توتر
الموقفورد استاذ العلاقات الدوليه المختص
بشؤون الاسيويه بجامعه اوكسفورد شكرا
جزيلا لك